welcome to this video playing zoo
shanghai the guy i donated quite a
number of rating points prosthetic it's
where he just blundered please quickly
which i failed to convert in the end
comedian loose it was a pretty
embarrassing game check so let's see is
going for the recursion this time it's
not so easy to blunder piece down
admittedly yeah that this line you for
widest some something that can be played
without any huge theoretical work note
that sets why i go for it okay why can I
not take d5 here I don't see a reason
actually Queen g6 why they why do they
play those kind of things where you
think a loop isn't this just a peace
upon or whatever or everybody plays
Bishop b6 damn probably for a reason 95
Queen g6 castles Bishop h3 this is
somehow working due to some miracle 91
I don't see it I simply don't see it I'm
going to take take that Bishop age 391
where is the where is the big point
ok
Bishop 3 is a move on I can just retreat
actually no reason not to I think also
might have 94 now 94 you will take H
true so that's not a great idea okay
let's just let's just go back down
okay I want you get this Bishop on the
six that looks like the only kind of
serious attacking piece that he has
and still cannot preserve the bishop
zone and some other useful moves to play
kd5 is not a great idea yeah you know
Bishop c4 was probably not really
helping very much can use this one
I wonder if he can play a forward at
some point and he might maybe he wants
to play Bishop I'm 55
and when to go Bishop c4
okay yeah i was thinking just defy here
maybe for the trade or queen d 5 is also
quite good you know 25 s actually a bit
better and then pawn to d5 so let's see
doubling down or just this yeah I can do
that right before Queen B 7 is certainly
good they have to be alert them I really
won a game within a complete piece up I
did not win this I even lost it on time
at the end against the sky in the end
gamer of the piece not some complicated
middle game
I'm not attacking the this but ok I'm
taking a five so guess we'll see seven
down
probably should be careful with those
end games that are winning if a piece up
was not enough what can I do with the
pawn up but ultimately am it was some
time loss so I want to be quick here as
quick as as possible that same I came
so no I'm can check actually check see
to get some time morning active in
myself Queen age 54 95 looks quite good
or is there something better there let's
let's play it look g6 is this saving him
I have Queen a 5 which is not bad i just
want to have there's something better
which is six night h form it's not
winning taking with the pondo threatens
95 again
check check may only has a check one
single check black resigns ok at least I
got one in one winner against him Jay I
was still kind of scary here after after
he I think he just blundered t5 yeah so
just take it I mean they all played by
Chevy 60 and it must have some kind of
reason that it is that they defend the
fire but it's still a bit just a little
bit tricky we are just back down
consolidating and itself I've got two
pawns in the center there so this is
never enough erm in any kind of firm
serious non blitz environment let's say
when in bits can be can be tricky I
didn't play it too well it it seems that
the comp is not objecting very much to
my play Joe I'm not sure actually here
maybe I could have taken but the point
is too strong ladies this is a straight
win all of the tongue jack check and was
what was the quickest after this I was
thinking he takes f probably still this
ok I see this is of course very very
strong now maybe maybe I would have seen
that after all that I'm just meeting
them yeah ultimately he cannot give me
the d5 pawn it's just well you can just
play for some tricks there but nothing
substantial ok well thanks for watching